wir sind in der ukraine auf dem
flughafen der hauptstadt kiew
der luzerner alexander hoch fliegt heute
zum letzten mal in den osten des landes
dort wird nach wie vor gekämpft was jede
woche sterben menschen
kühlborn stress sowie für jedermann
die noch 40 jahre oder länger
eine spezielle emotionen ohne jetzt
geht's
[Musik]
große emotionen sind nicht seine aufgabe
er muss so neutral wie möglich sein
alexander hug ist stellvertretender chef
beobachter der osze im ukraine krieg
seine arbeit hatte mithelfen sollen
frieden in dieses land zu bringen
nach viereinhalb jahren geht sein
einsatz zu ende
zurück bleibt der krieg was für ein
mensch muss man sein und kreuzfeuer
eines bewaffneten konfliktes scheinbar
emotionslos zu arbeiten
davon handelt diese film
[Musik]
rund 700 internationale beobachter
arbeiten in hochs mission mit einer
gruppe fährt er zur sogenannten kontakt
linie im äußersten osten in der ukraine
befindet sich diese kontakt linie die
eigentlich eine frontlinie ist rund 500
kilometer lang
hier kämpfen ukrainische
regierungstruppen gegen lokale
separatisten wie allerdings von russland
entscheidend unterstützt und wohl auch
befehligt werden
der kreml bestreitet das russland will
offensichtlich verhindern dass die
prowestliche regierung in kiew die
ukraine in die eu und in die nato führt
panzerwagen der ukrainischen regierung
drucken wir sind ganz nahe der front und
fahren ins lang umkämpfte dorffeste
[Musik]
zur ruhe gekommen ist das dorf seit
jahren nicht
um noch einwohner zu finden muss man
lange suchen
du hast aber kalte hände
es ist schon in ordnung er hat eine gute
die alte frau scheint alexander hoch
schon zu kennen
sie beklagt sich über die kämpfe eine
zeitlang flügel hier ständig die
granaten ums haus herum habe ich schon
38 ein schläger gezählt der hof und
alles ist kaputt
nur mein sohn und ich sehe auch hier ich
bin 80 und der 54 darum alexander hast
du besser auf dich selber auf deine
kinder und eine frau
ich werde sie niemals vergessen
ich werde dich auch nie vergessen mein
sohn
und das leben noch acht andere in
größeren verschlossen wird hier noch
chancen und werden frauen mit der nacht
aber mich sehr dass die hitze dezember
absetzten das militär das heißt sind
wahrscheinlich aussteller gehirn nach
wie das denn bringt auch immer die
zivilbevölkerung taktik vor
das leben der menschen hier erträglicher
zu machen dafür setzt sich auch seit
viereinhalb jahren ein
ein intensiver job für den juristen und
ehemaligen offizier der schweizer armee
meist müssen fünf stunden schlaf reichen
dabei war seine einsatzzeit ursprünglich
nur für sechs monate geplant
rosenqvist hat für die oxid das habe ich
noch in ein netz sein
er hatte zum zeitpunkt der verdanken
dass das meine volle konflikt wird für
wo so lange touren und zum zeitpunkt vom
heutigen tag noch keine lösung in sicht
wir holten die jüngste 5 - sie wo das
ganze angefangen hat und das heißt vier
inzwischen lauf statt und red was nun
folgt ist honig vor die heimat nach kiew
abgereist
mindestens eine woche pro monat waren
alexander ruhe in den letzten jahren im
konfliktgebiet
sich selber ein bild machen um danach
starke argumente zu haben für die
schwierigen verhandlungen mit den
militärischen und politischen
verantwortlichen us korrespondent war
ich selber oft in dieser region und habe
dabei alexander hug mehrmals getroffen
erstmals im juli 2014 hier vor den
trümmern der boeing malaysia airlines m
h 17 abgeschossen über dem
ostukrainischen himmel fast 300
unschuldige männer frauen und kinder
starben
die bilde mit hut bei der absturzstelle
gingen um die welt
damals konnte er zeigen weil ich es die
stärke seine mission ist er und seine
beobachter sind bestens vernetzt mit den
verschiedenen kriegsparteien die
kühlwagen mit den leichen waren damals
auf dem territorium der separatisten und
mussten über die frontlinie auf die
seite der regierungstruppen
transportiert werden
bouygues vermittelte
können sie mir ihr wort geben dass
dieser zug heute er wegfährt
wir müssen die leichenwagen jetzt
endlich weg bringen schon damals gab es
viele indizien dafür was wir aufgrund
der untersuchungsbericht der mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit wissen
es war eine rakete der russischen armee
die das flugzeug abgeschossen hatte auch
spekulationen ließ sich huck aber nie
ein spezial missionen schnitt dort zu
dort die untersuchungsführer oder die
licher zwerges und sie stolz sudo
spricht der was mission gesetz vor ort
und die bricht war der 57
mitgliedstaaten wie trickreich seit
jenen tagen ist heute 46 jährige hug
dass gesichter mission
er nimmt regelmäßig an patrouillen teil
will ein vorbild sein
oftmals wurde es gefährlich mehrmals
gerieten hug und andere beobachter unter
beschuss ein mitarbeiter stark nach
einer minenexplosion das hoch die
hotspots trotzdem regelmäßig besuchte
rechnen ihm hier auch die kämpfe um
militärs hoch an
wir fahren seiner ukrainischen
polizeiakademie
hier will hug einmal mehr die arbeit der
osze der organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa erklären
[Musik]
die osze ist die größte regionale
sicherheitsorganisation der welt sie
besteht aus 57 mitgliedstaaten darunter
auch russland und die ukraine
in minsk wurde im februar 2015
eigentlich eine waffenstillstand
ausgehandelt aber an den hält sich keine
der beiden seiten die osze mission in
der ukraine hat die aufgabe fakten
darüber zusammen wann und wo das
waffenstillstandsabkommen verletzt wird
so filmte drohnen wie russische konvois
wahrscheinlich militärische nachts
heimlich in die ukraine führen
oder wie getarnt der ukrainische haubitz
nahe der kontakt linie stehen wo sie
nicht sein dürften
über 10.000 menschen kam bis heute bei
diesem krieg ums leben oder tausende
mussten die heim verlassen
der westen sieht russland als treibende
kriegspartei und hält darum seit jahren
die sanktionen gegen russland aufrecht
in moskau sieht man es gerade umgekehrt
alexander hug weiß genau es geht hier im
ukrainischen den bass um geopolitik das
zeigt sich auch bei seinem nächsten
treffen hob empfängt eine delegation von
us amerikanischen diplomaten
ihre arbeit ist ja inzwischen legendär
wir würden gerne mehr wissen was
funktioniert und was nicht wohin die
mission geht und wie wir behilflich sein
könnten
ich selber muss draußen bleiben
ich frage mich ob auch hinter
verschlossenen türen radikal neutral ist
zwischen darf ich eine frage stellen die
amerikaner sind das ziemlich klar wenn
es um die rolle russlands in diesem
konflikt geht die osze ist eher
vorsichtigen schauen sich für uns ist es
ganz klar der fehler der russen
sie haben zuerst die creme annektiert
und sie beliefern die ostukrainischen
separatisten mit waffen und andere
unterstützer dafür machen wir sie
verantwortlich diplomatisch privatem er
nicht nur ein star sondern der staat
besitzt russland ist clara intel von
konflikten
das ist meine teilnahme start weg seit
ich vertrat der 750 seien gestalte ich
meine persönliche meinung die hat aber
dem technik
jugend seine beobachte notieren also
tausende von waffenstillstands
verletzungen
sie sagen auch wohnt war aber wer
schießt diese frage lassen sie offen
wir fahren noch einmal zur kontakt linie
wir wollen vom gebiet das von den
ukrainischen regierung strucken
kontrolliert wird auf die andere seite
zu den von russland unterstützten
separatisten eine grenze innerhalb eines
landes die es eigentlich gar nicht geben
dürfte
denn die menschen hier gehören zusammen
oft sind freunde oder familienmitglieder
voneinander getrennt
[Musik]
der übergang ist eine brücke die nur
mehr zu fuß passierbar ist
cook muss sich hier von seinen fahrern
verabschieden
für immer archivbilder der separatisten
zeigen wie 2014 um diese brücke hart
gekämpft wurde
[Musik]
2015 wurde sie gesprengt
seither können keine fahrzeuge mehr
passieren
tausende von menschen müssen täglich
eine lange strecke zu fuß gehen um ihre
renten gelder zu beziehen für spittal
besucher oder um angehörige zu sehen
links und rechts sind minenfelder
explosionen oder schüsse in der nähe
scheinen hier niemanden mehr sonderlich
zu beeindrucken
mehrere checkpoints muss man passieren
um über die brücke zu kommen das kann
stunden dauern
überall wo er auftritt wird er mit
derselben frage konfrontiert wann ist
das alles endlich vorbei ich hoffe bald
er macht doch nichts mehr hilft nicht es
geht uns hier genauso schlecht wie
früher
das ist doch kein zustand ständig muss
man zu fuß über dieser grenze immer zu
fuß eine zumutung
viele menschen hilfe stehen die aufgabe
der beobachter nicht fast schon
gebetsmühlenartig musik hug erklärt noch
einmal die mission hat in tausenden von
täglichen berichten dokumentiert wie die
menschen hier leiden und mit welchen
schwierigkeiten sie leben müssen
diese informationen sind für alle
zugänglich auch für diejenigen die hier
die entscheidungen treffen
genau diese entscheidungsträger müssten
aber die berichte lesen und dann
schritte einleiten um die situation zu
verbessern
die frustration der menschen buch
bekommt sie aufzuspüren
ich frage mich wo er bis zum letzten tag
seine motivation hin
schwierig sei ich weiß dass es möglich
ist der konflikt in die richtig richtig
drücken
und ich weiß dass oft gar oder einfach
der konflikt akzeptiere wenn er jetzt
stattfindet mit zur lösungsfindung
betreut
dann müssen wir noch über eine
provisorische holzbrücke auf die andere
seite
dort warten vertreter der pro russischen
separatisten bereits auf
[Musik]
guten tag wir haben sie vor einer stunde
erwartet
tut mir leid aber ich wollte hier noch
mit den menschen reden die von russland
unterstützten separatisten haben hier in
der region von logan skonto net zwei
selbständige republiken ausgerufen
man fühlt sich fast wieder wegen der
sowjetunion autoritäre militärregime die
die freiheitsrechte der menschen stark
einschränken
das gilt auch für die medien alexander
hug hält eine pressekonferenz
die anwesenden journalisten stellen vor
allem fragen im sinne der lokalen macht
haben die menschen hier beschuldigen die
osze oft dass diese mit der ukrainischen
armee und den geheimdiensten gemeinsame
sache machen können sie diese
zusammenarbeit kommentieren
[Musik]
wir haben ein mandat um mit allen
stellen in der ukraine kontakte zu haben
auf beiden seiten der linie
nach viereinhalb jahren sollte man
endlich aufhören gegenseitig mit dem
finger aufeinander zu zeigen
das hat bis heute nichts gebracht das
gilt auch für euch journalisten
wir alle sollten versuchen die
entscheidungsträger dahingehend zu
beeinflussen dass diese lösungen finden
und nicht noch mehr probleme schaffen
letzte pressekonferenz endet aber
keineswegs im streit die medien
vertreten möchten noch 111 mit ihm akw
seine arbeit gut gemacht erzählt mir
eine journalistin
ganz anders tönt es dann am abend als
ich im hotel die lokalen verse
nachrichten schaue hat oftmals völlig
grundlos die behörden von so ganz
beschuldigt sie würden die arbeit der
beobachter behindern immer wieder
erfindet er vorwürfe gegenüber logan
skonto netz gleichzeitig hat er stets
daran gearbeitet die verbrechen der
ukrainischen terroristen zu vertuschen
kaum zu glauben wie hochs worte verdreht
werden am nächsten tag hagelt es
nochmals kritik diesmal von ukrainischer
seite
geplant war eigentlich zivilisten an der
frontlinie zu besuchen doch das fällt
aus alle scheinen angespannt in der
nacht wurde hoch in einer bekannten
amerikanischen zeitung falsch zitiert er
habe gesagt es gebe keine beweise für
eine russische militärpräsenz in der ost
ukraine die ukrainische medien laufen
sturm
hohe regierungsvertreter schießen gegen
hoch einen ganzen tag lang kommunizieren
er und sein ganzes team mit ukrainischen
journalisten und politikern die nicht
böse dass er uns vor schluss blieb und
und einfach immer nur sachlich neutral
und das der niedermühle kann auf den
tisch klopfen zeigen so die sind jetzt
schuldig auch früh erklärt dass es dem
umfeld von dem konflikt es gar nicht
bringt wenn man emotional reagiert oder
sogar eins etabliert werden über kurz
oder lang weder bestandteil von problem
und werden unbrauchbar als lösung finden
mich
unterstütze aber auf die lange sicht und
auf eine nachhaltige lösung spending
ausgerichtet würde es immer sehr ans
handeln mitbringen eine rationale
antwort
trotzdem spüre ich dass hug die
unterstellungen und anfeindungen
nahegehen dazu äußern will es sich aber
nicht um nicht noch mehr öl ins feuer zu
gießen
wir fahren ein letztes mal an den
stadtrand von donetsk in einen
umkämpften außenbezirk dort passieren
wir den letzten checkpoint separatisten
danach sind wir in der sogenannten
grauen zone
wir sind die menschen sich selbst
überlassen
wir hören dass in der ferne geschossen
wird das gespräch mit der bevölkerung
wird von uniformierten separatisten
überwacht
für uns wäre das wichtigste dass der
beschuss aufhört
wir träumen einfach von einem normalen
leben aber sie waren doch schon hier bei
uns vor zwei jahren erinnern sie sich
als die alte frau so gemeint hat
so in der tauchte letzte der vielen
front besucher mit der frage auf die
alexander hug keine antwort geben kann
wann das alles aufhört
hug weiß genau dass diese konflikte
gelöst werden kann wenn sich der westen
und russland wieder näher kommen
zum abschied kann er den mitarbeitern
motor halte parolen mit auf den weg
geben
[Musik]
ich bitte euch macht weiter mit eurer
arbeit gibt nicht auf auch wenn sie euch
sehr frustrierend erscheint eine
endgültige lösung für die beendigung des
konfliktes ist nicht gesicht aber wir
wissen alle konflikte enden früher oder
später
und so wird auch dieser ändern und ihr
habt dabei eine rolle zu spielen und
eine panzersperre das ist für diese
region passen
ich will ihnen danke sagen im namen von
uns allen
sie waren immer ein vorbild vor aus zwei
gründen wegen ihrer integrität und ihren
mutigen einsatz
das ist das was ihnen jeder von uns das
ganze team mit geben möchte
wie seine zukunft aussehe bisher noch
nicht
zuerst will er zeit mit der familie und
seinen eltern verbringen
aber es gebe interessante optionen
zb eine mission in syrien
[Musik]